so we're here at the London Film and
Comic Con today with Hit Girl
tell me about this outfit you put
together well my mom mode made the cape
and the waistcoat and the skirt but we
keep this kind of short notice because
we didn't really know we were going
until a couple of days ago so we put it
together quite quickly but we think it
looks pretty good it looks very good
thank you worried about hit girl he
likes a man I think that's because she's
really quite different other superheroes
be honest because she's like this is a
younger girl it's really different to
pretend to be her and you get less
different reactions from it as well and
it looks really good now you founded the
movies we've had one so far we got
another one coming up yeah that really
good my sister got me into them and
we're probably gonna go see their new
one when it comes out what do you like
about clay Moretz that she's great I
think I pick girls she's really good
she's like a really good actress and
she's like her parents is really good
when she see her it looks pretty good
she's real kick ass isn't it yes she's
really really good and what are you
looking forward to would kick ass too
just kind of gettin see more of them
because no other film came out quite a
while ago and it's good to see them back
on and because they don't have daddy
cool anymore there'll be new characters
and we already assume
you